We do have a representative
from Tennessee, Jerry Faison.
He is the Tennessee
Republican caucus chair joining us now.
And good evening. Thanks for joining us.
Can you just kind of explain to us
why you believe these two members
have just been expelled?
Thank you. That that's a great question.
First of all, I'd like to say
this is a terribly sad time.
This is a very grave situation
that someone would be expelled.
Before that,
we've had some serious tragedies
in Tennessee.
And the six innocent lives
that were lost last week
are are absolutely devastating.
So
I want to make sure that we mention that
that that's
one of the biggest things going on
right now in Tennessee.
You asked me specifically about
why do I think they should be expelled?
I think that's a great question.
America deserves to know.
We have several hundred years
over 200 years of of of
of an incredible state,
incredible state house history.
That's rich
Tennessee
is one of the most important states
in all of America.
We have had literally thousands
of state reps
since 1796 who have who have worked.
And then after 1859 have worked
in this very chamber
that you're seeing me in today.
They have all understood
that there are rules
and procedures to ensure
that every voice is heard.
There's almost 7 million Tennesseans,
and we have come up with these ideas
that the best way
for everybody to be heard
is to make sure
that we follow the rules of decorum.
So these members have come
in this entire. Go ahead.
Let me just representative there
interrupt to say I understand decorum.
Van was just making the point there.
Of course,
not everyone
can bring a bullhorn in every time
they disagreed.
Otherwise it would be total chaos.
But why take this step?
Why was there
no measure you could have taken
before this, before expulsion?
Why take the most extreme step
so quickly?
So that's an excellent question.
More than just
what America has seen
that took place last Thursday,
there is a history
all year long of disrupting
committees and the House floor
getting off of the germane topic.
When I say germane,
that is what we're dealing
with at that moment.
Just to make political grandstand,
we've called them out.
The chairmen of committees,
the speaker of the House
have been calling them out,
Tom and Tom again for grabbing the mic,
sucking the air out of the room,
making sure no other voices heard.
And finally, when they come
and and act
so foolish on the House floor,
this is a sacred place
that belongs to everybody
and literally start
looking up into the gallery
with a bullhorn,
getting the protesters
worked up into a frenzy.
That is incumbent on us to say
you've gone a step too far
and we're going to take steps
to make sure
that if you ever do come back,
if you get reelected,
that, you know, it's a serious thing
to Tennesseans
that you come and disrupt
the people's house.
So I think it was very,
very important for us to do that.
The speaker here
likened what they did
to what happened on January six
in Washington, D.C..
Do you agree with that comparison?
I believe them coming in
and taking over the house.
They called it occupying the well.
The where's
the well is where we send up front
to pass our bills.
That that is
that is incredibly disruptive
and embarrassing
to the legislature,
the institution that we have here.
And I didn't see anybody in Congress
try to take over.
Now, I saw some really big idiots
that I hope are punished
to the full extent of the law.
Come and break into the Capitol
and act foolish on January six.
But I didn't see a congressman act
this way.
What we saw here in Tennessee
is three elected state representatives
who know the rules,
who understand
that this place belongs to everybody.
They come in and rush up here
and take over the House floor and refuse.
Even when our sergeant arms.
He's a gentle soul.
Several of them are just great men.
Come and gently encourage them.
Gus, not right now.
Listen, don't do this.
I mean, they told.
They sent them away.
It was. It was.
It's an embarrassment to everybody
to see someone come and behave like that.
And good, gentle souls
who are sergeant
arms have been here for years.
Come in and try to encourage you.
Hey, you're making a mistake.
And they didn't do it.
And I'd like to add to your
they they've not backed down
from that either.
You know,
I told them earlier that I feel like
if they would have said, you know what,
we messed up.
I mean, what American wouldn't
Tuman bring forgiveness and redemption.
But they doubled down
and went so far as to stain in the world
today and said I'd do it again.
That was their mentality.
That shows me
when there's
a pattern of behavior like that.
If you refuse to stop it yourself,
then we have to step in
as a group of individuals
that work with you and say
you're not do that here.
Well,
they said they were passionate
because of the underlying reason
that I think is important here
to also remind people,
which is because six people were killed
in a shooting last week.
And just on your point on January six,
the reason the
Congress that we're doing this,
because they were being evacuated,
because the insurrectionists
were taking over the Capitol.
But I do want my colleague
here, Van Jones,
he also has a question for you.
And thank you
again for being here tonight.
Thank you for for joining us.
I just wonder,
there are people who are members
of that state legislature.
And by the way, I work for a gymnasium.
Speaker Nancy,
I got my start in the state legislature.
So it's a friend, exactly.
One of the best ever.
And I'm from from Madison County,
born in Jackson, Tennessee.
So so I know how things work
in that state legislature.
And you have an array of tools
as a leader to get people to comply.
Why did you not go to the Ethics
Committee?
Why did you not go through due process?
If you are here saying you want
this legislator to be respected.
Why are you not following the rules
and using the tools that you have?
You want them to not be extreme,
but you're being extreme. Why is that?
Our democracy.
So a lot of
accusation on your part there.
We actually are following the rules
and we gave them ample chance.
We established
what was taking place on Monday.
There was due process.
Did you go make it?
It's not just up to me.
There's there's actually,
you know, of 71,
I think, or
70 of the members who after looking at
what took place today, they voted two
to expel one of them, one in 69
from that committee.
And just try to understand,
why did you not go to
the Ethics Committee
and do the things
that are always done in that body?
You have not done this to anybody
except for two people in 200 years.
You can't tell me that
there have not been people
who have also been disrupted,
that you've had
people have peed on chairs
that did not get expelled.
So I don't understand
why you skipped the Ethics Committee.
If you want respect
and if you want
for people to be reasonable,
why are you being so unreasonable
and why are you skipping steps?
I don't understand.
You seem to be contradicting.
You're not acting the way you want.
The young people act.
So the story of someone urinated on
some of somebody's
stairs is never been quantified.
I've heard many people say
they don't think there's
any truth to that.
So what you need to understand is
this is a body of people
who decide corporately
what we're going to do moving forward.
This body spoke many times.
I brought our caucus together
several times since last Thursday
to ask the body what we as a group
wanted to do.
The overwhelming majority,
the heartbeat of this caucus
is not on this House floor, not this way.
So if there was an idea of
send it to the ethics group,
this group, my caucus,
which is the super majority
there, 75 of us said, no,
that is not
we don't want to go to the ethics rep.
We don't want them censured.
We want them expelled.
So when you're in leadership,
you encourage people
to look at all the aspects
and then you work with what
the majority of your people want to do.
And that's exactly what we did.
Sara Sara Sidner, I had a question.
You mentioned
that you thought that the representatives
were riling up the crowd.
And I can tell you from the reporters
that were out there,
the crowd was already riled up.
They are extremely upset
that your legislature
wasn't trying to deal with the issue
of keeping children safe in school,
but instead
going after these two Democrats.
And I wonder, sir, who are you punishing?
Because, yes,
you have kicked out these two Democrats,
but there are tens
of thousands of constituents
that are also being punished
and don't have any representation
right now.
What do you say to them?
So, first of all,
the censure, the part that you said
you didn't think
the crowd was already worked up,
so they weren't working up.
I'd like you to go back and watch.
Watch what took place today.
They literally control the crowd.
They control the protesters.
They look at them.
They do their hand like this.
It's like leading the choir.
So the notion that you think
that they weren't
getting the people incited
and worked up into a frenzy,
unfortunately weren't here.
You didn't see it.
That's exactly what they did.
And they protest today.
But stand up and tell them
they talked to some of them
and some of them were teachers
who were so distraught
they were near tears
because they could not believe
that their lawmakers
were doing this
as opposed to dealing
with the biggest issue at hand.
The number one
killer of children is gun violence,
and they wanted you
all to do something about that
instead of wasting time and their mind
when it comes to this.
I mean, they literally
talked about it on the air.
So they were already quite worked up
because they love their state
and they love their kids
and they want to
see a safer place for the children
and themselves, really.
So I'm sure that's what you think.
But we watched them
today, directed them
like a choir leader would.
That was what was amazing.
And I'll tell you this
and unfortunately, I've got to go.
I'm I'm three and a half hours from home.
Compelling argument
I think you've reached an
it's not possible for us to move forward
with the way
they were behaving in committee
and on the House floor.
There's got to be some peace.
And for them,
the way they were behaving
to disrupt every committee, disrupt
the House floor, they were.
How can we get to the
to the answers of
what are we going to do
about gun violence?
What are we going to do
about guns and college?
What are we going to do about red flag?
Well,
the conversation can't happen
because they're drowning out,
sucking all the air out of the room.
So I would just push back on you saying
we can't get there
if they won't let us.
And thank you
for letting me speak with you.
God bless. Representative.
Representative,
I know you got a long drive home.
One final question for you.
All right.
Well, Jeremy Faison has left us
is the Republican chair in Tennessee.
Of course,
that was the House
and voted tonight to expel
these two Republicans or these
two Democrats, I should note.